(audience cheering)
- What's up, everybody?
We're back with Lauren Graham and Mo Amer,
give it up. (clapping)
(audience applauding)
So that was the look at
Mo's Netflix show, "MO."
Do you really carry olive oil with you?
- I used to regularly
carry olive oil with me
and I just ruined too many clothes.
Like, you just.
- Oh, exactly.
(Lauren laughs)
- The madness had to stop.
I had to just like submit and just use-
- [Kelly] I love olive oil.
- Yeah, it's a big thing
for us for sure.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You could wear it, you
could use it for your skin,
use it for your hair.
- (laughs) Multipurpose.
- You could drink it.
Yeah, no, it's a whole
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 'nother situation.
- They always do that for vocals
when we were younger they'd
be like, take some olive oil.
I was like, "Is this fine?"
- Really?
- And then, yeah.
I don't feel like it helped,
but they, whatever.
(Mo and audience laughing)
They'd give you whatever if you're sick.
And I'd be like, "Alright."
So where exactly did you grow up?
'Cause I knew you were
in Texas for a lot of
your young life, right?
- Yeah, the whole series
was filmed in Houston,
the vast majority of it.
We filmed it out of a suburb called Alief,
which has over 90 languages
spoken in Alief alone.
- That's cool.
- One of the most diverse
neighborhoods in America.
And I just thought it was absurd,
there's never been a series,
narrative sitcom filmed out of Houston.
Fourth largest city, huge
exporter of great music.
- Yeah.
- And just never has had
its flowers, in my opinion.
- [Kelly] Great rodeos.
- Yeah. Great rodeo, yeah.
- (laughs) I've been there.
So how did you support yourself
while working on your comedy in Houston?
- When I was, I started stand-up
when I was 14 years old.
- [Lauren] Wow.
- And-
- That's brave.
- [Lauren] Yeah.
- Yeah, I came over as
a refugee immigrant to
America when I was nine.
So I didn't necessarily have
like a social security number,
couldn't get a job,
started working very young,
and became an entrepreneur,
you could say. (chuckles)
At like 14, I would sell
fake, I'll just spit it out,
I sold fake Versaces!
(Lauren and audience laughing)
- Ver-sak-ee.
- Fake goods. Yeah. (laughs)
Ver-say-see, I sold the hell out of it.
- Yeah, for some Goo-key. (laughs)
- I would put on like a
dope pair of sunglasses
and you know, somebody would see them,
be like, "Hey man, those are really fly."
I was like, "Yeah, it's my last pair,"
and you could have 'em.
And I'd give 'em a price
and they would buy 'em.
Once they'd leave, I'd put on
another pair of sunglasses.
(Lauren and audience laughing)
It's just that. That's how it worked.
- Well you fit right in,
in Texas. (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- With the salesmen, that's awesome.
Have you ever bought anything knockoff?
Have you ever done...
- Yeah. Oh, a 1000%.
- [Mo] Yeah.
- But that's a really good
sales tactic. (laughs)
(Mo and audience laughs)
The old, the only one left.
- [Mo] It's the craziest-
- It's on my face.
- At the end of the week,
they'll just all be
wearing the same stuff.
They all know each other
from the same neighborhood.
So they'll come back
at me with some anger,
like, "You told me it was the last one."
I was like, "At that
moment, it was the last one.
But I do have another one of a kind here."
(Lauren and Kelly laugh)
(audience laughs)
- I got a shipment in. (laughs)
- I swear. I would sell it, it would sell.
- [Kelly] (laughs) Oh my God.
- I'm not even kidding.
- So your show, you said it's
based on your real life.
- Yeah.
- So go back and, is it hard to go back
and relive some of those
things in the episodes?
- Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, some of them are
really difficult memories
of you know, fleeing war,
to coming to Houston.
I recreated the home that
we fled from in Kuwait.
That was really special and unique,
and my mom would just cry immediately
when she watched that flashback.
And yeah, it was just
really, really special
and to you know, bring back your father,
essentially bringing him back to life
and recreating really painful memories,
at the same time is very cathartic
to just put that out there.
In some cases I realized
I didn't even deal
with those things in my regular life.
And as we were filming
I was like, "Ah, man."
- [Kelly] It's like therapeutic.
- It's really therapeutic.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was really rewarding to do that.
- A beautiful way to honor him as well.
That's cool. Yeah.
- Absolutely.
- So you included a
special tribute to your mom
in one of the episodes, right?
- Absolutely.
- Yeah?
What was that like?
- So you know, the dedicated,
the episode two is called Yamo,
which is a Syrian slang term for mother.
And there was a song that was
on a classic Syrian TV show
called (speaks arabic),
which is named after its main character.
I've seen my father cry
on two separate occasions,
was when my grandmother passed away
and when he was watching this
particular scene from (speaks arabic),
and they were singing a song called Yamo.
And the entire song is
essentially a prayer for mothers.
It's, you know, nine
months you carried me.
How many times did I make you tired
while you were raising me?
How many pairs of socks
did you dry out for me?
How many times did you
go hungry to feed me?
It is just really, really special.
And the end of it is
like an entire prayer is,
you know only God is enough for you.
And may God give you a
long life and preserve you.
It was just so sweet.
And that song was super hard to get
because how do you get
a song that came out
on a classic TV show in the Middle East?
There's no like-
- Copyright? No, yeah.
- There's no roadmap to that.
So our great music
supervisor, Suhel Nafar,
got in touch with (speaks arabic),
the creator of the
show, in war-torn Syria.
And I got a letter from him directly,
saying that I can use the song
for the show, 30 years later.
And I put it over my mom making olive oil
in the series as a dedication to mothers.
- Oh my gosh.
(audience applauding)
I love how meaningful that is.
Like, it's so thoughtful.
- Yeah. You're gonna make me cry on
daytime television.
- [Kelly] I'm so sorry.
- This is ridiculous.
- No, I just think it's
such a beautiful thing
and that's what I love about music,
I feel so blessed to be a part of it
because it's like they're memories.
Like music is almost like
memories, like smells.
You know, like the one you
won't tell us you're wearing.
- [Mo] Yes.
(Lauren and audience laughing)
- They're nostalgic.
Like, it's like a nostalgia that you get
with certain things in life,
and music is one of them.
It's beautiful.
- [Mo] No absolutely-
- 30 years later it's
still impacting people.
- Yeah, I saw that when I was like
five, six years old and to have it
in my own series,
- [Kelly] Cool.
- this many years later,
is just incredible, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- How can you write that?
Like, all the things that had to happen
for me to be where I am today.
For my mom to flee
Palestine, end up in Kuwait.
To flee war in Kuwait to
end up in Houston, Texas.
To go to the Houston
Livestock Show and Rodeo
when I was 10 to see live
comedy for the first time,
"I'm gonna be a comedian."
Four years later, I'm doing
standup, and now I'm here.
It's just crazy.
(audience applauding)
- That is crazy, it's awesome.
And do you think like, cause
I was a cocktail waitress
at a comedy club before all of this.
- [Mo] Oh, were you really?
- I was, and-
- Me too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mo] Were you really?
- I think
I knew this about you.
And I love though, like, I
feel like a lot of comedians,
it's so funny because there
can be kind of a dark past,
something that happened that almost
made them find humor.
- Sure.
- Do you think, 'cause like,
I'm like picturing you one
to nine years old like,
in a war-ridden, like that
had to have been hard.
- It was hard.
- Do you think that that has
kind of fueled you like to find humor?
- Absolutely, it was
incredibly therapeutic,
and the way I got into it was,
in high school, my father passed away.
I started skipping class all the time.
I was living Ferris Bueller's Day Off.
I would go to baseball games.
(Kelly and Lauren laugh)
I just didn't care, and my
teacher just realigned me.
She said, "Don't you wanna
be a stand-up comedian?
You need to graduate and find a purpose.
I'll tell you what, I'll let you do
stand-up in class every Friday."
Mrs. Reed, shout out Mrs. Reed,
Mrs. Brodrick.
- That's cool.
- And I did standup.
She goes, "As long as you
can include Shakespeare
in your standup here and there, I will,
you know give you extra credit."
I was like, all about it.
- Challenge accepted.
- I was like, "To be or not to be."
(Kelly and audience laugh)
You know, it was like
immediately.
And then she took me to theater
arts department weeks later.
She's like, "This kid's
been doing original stand-up
and doing all these accents.
I think he belongs here."
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And then I started getting
lead roles in theater
and just became an honorary thespian.
And she changed my life.
Yeah, she changed my life.
- Isn't that,
I love teachers so much.
- [Mo] Yeah, yeah.
- We talk about it all
(audience applauds)
the time on the show.
My mama was a teacher. They're angels.